[Applause]
my name is Sebastian Savannah in front
of audacity I'm super super elated to
have with me one of the true leaders
pioneers and today's contemporary
international figures in the age of
artificial intelligence Kai fully -
welcome thank you thank you I would I
would introduce you the same way Kai
fool actually just wrote a book it's a
probably colored red it's called aya AI
superpowers China's Silicon Valley a new
world order and he's right now on a u.s.
book tour it's selling and record levels
I'm my girlfriend loves the book so do i
and you're here with us at Udacity to
answer questions and give us some
insights yep so welcome say I've known
Kyle for long I can imagine he was deaf
here back in the day when I was an
exchange student master students that
can email and he was the guy next to our
new faculty member and I still remember
that the faculty at Carnegie Mellon
believed that never had a superstar like
him among themselves and then he moved
to Microsoft Google and eventually to
China studies on venture firms in a
venture in China in the book when it
goes straight to the chase here in the
book you're telling us about AI in China
right what's different in China from the
United States well China started very
much behind there were a lot of decent
AI researchers in China I was fortunate
in 98 to have found the Microsoft
Research Asia I think which ended up
training pretty much the whole
generation of AI people in China but
yeah I wasn't in vogue back then it was
kind of a not very popular we didn't
even want to use the word AI there was a
saying that when it works is product
engineering whatever it doesn't work is
AI so we were in that state for quite a
while but then us deep learning geoff
hinton and others really demonstrated
that AI can solve a lot of narrow
problems extremely well
and and China is was behind but it had
this backbone of pretty smart
researchers and then some of the early
China companies Baidu
and sign ovations the companies we
funded we're doing some work but it's
really tiny compared to us but what
happened was when alphago beat léa
Seydoux that woke all of China up that
this ancient game requiring not just
intelligence but wisdom that how could a
US UK company just be the best player in
Asia
then there's must be something about
about alphago about AI and then China
went on fire in the last two and a half
years with entrepreneurs VC's government
all injecting money talent resources and
in the short two and a half years China
has caught up with the u.s. in
implementation monetization and
valuation of AI and that's what this
book is about is a magical two and a
half years seems not like an impossible
task mission impossible but it happened
so the Chinese government has announced
putting tens of billions of dollars into
AI yes what does it mean and should be
the same in this country oh well first
what does it mean
it actually means infrastructure
spending I think the Chinese government
is not picking winners governments
aren't very good at picking winners in
technology so there for example putting
in huge amounts of money to build a new
city the size of Chicago that has
autonomous driving built in and within
that city the center of the town will
have two layers the pedestrians pets
bicycles will go on a top green very
park beautiful place with no cars all
the cars autonomous or not will drive in
be one in that downtown I mean you can
imagine the expense but that's the kind
of effort that I think will make
autonomous
driving safe in in the most potentially
hazardous area that is downtown busy
traffic with people avoiding cars ever
hitting people so Joe John province is
building a new highway with sensors that
will talk to cars to give cars a lower
chance of having accidents so I think
that kind of large infrastructure spend
is the largest obviously there's also
money being put into AI parks the city
of Nanjing chose a gigantic area I think
I think about two million square feet of
space to be its new AI park and because
Nanjing had really great schools and
they now want to say hey I is our big
big area so I think infrastructure spend
like this are the most powerful there's
some money being put into AI funds that
are investing so so yes a lot of money's
being put in and I think it's largely in
infrastructure Advanced Research making
sure that companies can get get funding
and their profits can take off and yes I
think us should do something like it if
if that money can be found in the budget
yeah
so so in your book you talked a bit
about the value as you talk about what
drives the Chinese entrepreneur what
makes people successful can you can you
tell us more about that
the Chinese thinking about
intrapreneurship about giving big
businesses yeah well I'm a big admirer
of Silicon Valley and but I've also
become a big admirer of the Chinese
entrepreneurship style and I think
that's very important to iterating with
AI so you know in Silicon Valley there's
the Steve Jobs with iPhone that's the
typical
what you're doing with Kittyhawk another
great example and Udacity is not a
company
well Udacity is a bit more like Chinese
style okay well I think you know
Kittyhawk iPhone is like brilliant
breakthrough technology that's gonna
change the world
it's a lightbulb goes off and brillian
scientists leading forward I think
Udacity is wonderful but it's more you
know operational excellence getting more
people getting more content so that's
actually something that Chinese really
excel at and in the book I talk about
you know in the u.s. there's a book
called the lean startup but actually
China does the link startup better than
Silicon Valley and also takes the lean
startup from zero to one and then one to
a million
so because the Chinese entrepreneurial
environment is very very tough people
compete fiercely in the book I talk
about it's like Coliseum where
gladiators are thrown in and only one
will survive and and also there's not
much frowning on copycats I'm not
talking about IP theft I'm just talking
about taking the look and feel from
another product within legal bounds so
or a feature so in that kind of
environment companies will the only way
companies can win is by building a
product that is impregnable uncopyable
so the examples are given the book are
the Chinese Yelp or Groupon called
matron it would go through there's so
much trouble and depth to create and an
infrastructure that will change the way
Chinese people eat and once you build
that infrastructure competitors can't
copy it or it's too expensive to copy
and that infrastructure essentially
allows food delivered to your home
within 30 minutes you'd have a choice of
maybe 500 restaurants before you leave
work you choose what you want to eat
when you're home in 30 minutes the food
is there waiting for you and it's the
cost of delivery is about 70 cents and
the way in which they achieve that
operational excellence is by grinding
away a few cents a week a month figuring
out new ways how to find people who will
work for less money how to find cheaper
ways of transportation such as cheap
cheaper electrical mopeds
and then how to deal with change of
batteries so it's and also the people
since they're not making a lot of money
there will be turnover so that's why
having an HR process that has six
hundred thousand people with massive
turnover every year all this to Silicon
Valley feels like a lot of operational
burden but by doing it well and getting
the delivery down to 70 cents you've
essentially erected a very high wall
around your business so that your
competitor if they want to do the same
they have to spend a few billion dollars
like the Amazon play where we are Jeff
Bezos said and thin margins I'm proud of
it it is it is like that Eric Schmidt
recently very famously said in a
confidential meeting that made it to the
press that he sees there being two
versions of the internet that we walk
but isn't it one by the world and maybe
a Chinese internet one by China mmm what
do you think about that well if you look
at my phone in my apps they completely
differ from yours so from that
perspective absolutely that the Chinese
people are using all Chinese apps and
they've gotten very good you know
we chat is better better than whatsapp I
saw that you are still using whatsapp
I'm not quite yet using whatsapp what
was that that you use less than text
messaging what text message oh my god
it's me
the CEO of Kitty Hawk using text
messaging I mean we chat well the
Chinese apps are really really good and
actually they're the apps are not there
they're very the ones that were inspired
by the US often they get better than the
u.s. not always often and the one there
are many now that are not inspired by
the u.s. they're Chinese innovation like
there is there are two social networks
with video they don't exist here yet and
there's a gamma fication of e-commerce
that in three years became twenty five
billion dollars so all these concepts
are now innovative in China the apps are
different the Chinese users don't use
much American apps and vice versa so I
think in that sense I speaking about
this I mean there's a whole bunch of
companies it has to be no exception who
tries to do business in China and it
starts opening offices in China building
joint ventures or similar vehicles
what's the advice for an American
company who wants to go into the Chinese
business well I think your dad city is
actually a very exceptional case I think
because what you carry is education and
that's dear and common to all the people
so there are a few such things that can
potentially cross us in China called
pure core technology companies
educational content entertainment are
probably three that I think can cross
the boundaries all the other things it
will be very very tough take in a Google
Facebook Amazon
or uber Airbnb they will all have a very
hard time in China and why is that well
the Chinese parallel universe has been
established people have established
patterns of how they use WeChat Alibaba
Taobao and so on and the brands are
established the apps are very easy to
use they cater to the Chinese Way and
they're intertwined in the way that you
know if if you use the Chinese right
sharing system then you're naturally
going to use WeChat which is then
naturally going to cause you to use
WeChat pay so these things are like a
puzzle put together if you now grab
Amazon and say we're gonna put that
puzzle and make it fit in that piece of
the puzzle fit in this this already
completely Chinese puzzle it just
doesn't fit so my advice to most
American companies that want to go to
China are is don't unless you are unless
you are you know education technology
license entertainment those areas I
think are ok I mean over time I do hope
the two universes will have a chance to
cross but right now it's just very
understand when it come back to your
book this is gonna be the book to read
for everybody for a long time to come in
my opinion and I should say Kai fully is
truly apparently effect when I joined
Carnegie Mellon my first program was to
work on technical bill which was a
world-class machine learning
player designed by a professor called KY
fully misses next to me and the either
he's a world-class program I can I can
attest to this but I've only asked about
the AI end game so he he is now in
everybody's mind we have people like
ulamas saying AI will eat us for
breakfast Stephen Hawking says is the
biggest threat in humanity Bill Gates
has been skeptical about it what is the
endgame well I think we cannot project
an endgame when we don't know the next
20 moves we're talking about you know a
fellow and go right right now we have a
narrow AI which is within a single
domain you can train brilliant systems
that can play go that can make decisions
for long officers advertising agents
accountants paralegal reporters I think
we're at the stage where we have this
blossoming of narrow AI and then the
chasm between narrow AI - generally I at
the so called endgame of human
intelligence is it's like a black dark
hole that I can't see any moves
that's it will clearly get us from here
to there so my opinion is that I think
of narrow AI not as a first step but as
maybe the most important step and it is
like electricity where apps can be built
and it will create so much value and
wealth and also displace a lot of jobs
and present challenges so I this book is
actually just saying this first step is
really important let's play it right and
then if there's another step we got to
survive the first step and make humanity
better so I don't talk about the
anything dude do you think about I do
believe in general artificial
intelligence I do not why not I choose
to believe that we have a soul and that
it cannot be replicated I know this may
be may not be the most popular view
within the AI geeky community I do
believe that without us soul we can't
accomplish
a machine that can do many different
tasks I do I believe we can but to be so
I think I see narrow AI becoming smarter
you know it will have more more
capabilities autonomous driving
I mean Kittyhawk those are great
examples that that single task is
already multi complex tasks but I don't
think Kitty Hawk has a soul I don't I
don't think it can understand compassion
and empathy and I don't think people
want to have a robot to take care of
them be their nanny and nurse and doctor
and teacher let me push this a little
bit so if I gave you a machine and say
this is a piece of AI and I can take
care of elderly people well how would
you tell whether the machine has a soul
or not
well I would say elderly people don't
want it so it's if they don't want the
product then it won't succeed I've
actually had a entrepreneur build a
pretty good robot for elderly care and
it turns out the elderly people you only
use one function and that's called
customer service so they push customer
service to talk to a person a video
video comes up and then the elderly
person says why hasn't my daughter
called today you know let me tell you
about my grandson and and I think there
is an innate desire for people to
interact with other people so even if
the robot became quite good it won't be
the choice by the pinna there has been
work on the eye just to push a little
harder here okay that you seen from
universe of watching other places that
people are able to synthesize famous
individuals like President Barack Obama
in a way that looks believable
- in fact udacity in his work with
Georgia Tech yeah
it should take professor a bit in online
agent and on an ta that throughout the
entire class acted like a TA and when
the class was over
professor disclose was actually a piece
of AI not a human being and every
student was gonna be surprised do you
think we cannot cross the chasm where we
we find AI agents believable I think we
can we can make them believable for
certain tasks and there are many tasks
for which we
really don't need a human interaction
the teaching assistant may just as well
be duolingo right or it could be doesn't
have to be answer for more Feist I think
there are many things that require that
human connection and that that I don't
see any progress that gives me
confidence we can make cross that bridge
and and if that bridge is meant to be
you know we really build something
that's completely indistinguishable from
human I think it potentially brings
disasters to us
supposing is doable in the sense that
what is the purpose and the meaning of
our lives and and I think I think that
will then cause a likely dystopia so I
am I'm not saying it's impossible to
build a machine with a soul but I think
we have to right now not believe it
because I think having our soul in
humanity is important and there and that
for people who choose to go after it
they of course have have the freedom to
but I think for the most of us I think
we need to hang on to our humanity
believe that we are unique and and have
our soul and in the end of the day I
think we if we are right then then we
never fall into a downward vicious cycle
of feeling the worthlessness and then
even in the case where wrong I think
believing we have a soul will make our
lives more worth living even if a
hundred years later
Sebastian's student proves that we were
wrong this 100 years will be better
lives even if we're wrong there's a
window left I think this is a really
insightful let me change gears a little
bit so so if you are a large-scale
company you're like an AT&T or Verizon a
a healthcare company a cardinal health
and you decide you heard about AI and
news you read Caiphas book anyone engage
what do advise companies to do well they
have to recognize a is coming and for
the sake of their shareholders and their
company's survival they need to look at
how to apply AI and make more money as
well as to displace humans in many of
the jobs that narrow AI can do and also
I think in doing so they need to take
our responsibilities of the employees
they will displace over the next five
years are not just objects because if
every company only optimizes shareholder
value there will be tens of millions of
people on the streets because AI has
taken their job and they can't find
another job because whatever they can do
AI can do better because AI will be
displacing the most routine the least
skilled jobs and and the hardest for
people to find a new job so I'd like to
think that a large company that can reap
the rewards of using AI to displace its
workers all to also have the
responsibility to find training to help
the employees find jobs that are not
immediately displaced or hopefully never
displace my yeah which I should say 18t
has been doing very massively but let's
dive into this do you think yeah I will
be a speakers like the fourth Industrial
Revolution services and absolutely and
and what fraction of the the labor force
in developing developed world nations
like China United States do you think is
it's going to be replaced I think if we
project further 15 to 25 years yes
probably about 50% 50% what McKinsey
says what temp drops do you think are
most under fire right now at this moment
it's not so bad at this moment actually
a is creating a lot of jobs right people
taking audacity getting into AI and
again at is creating a lot of jobs for
people who have the potentials skillset
and interests
and the actual displacement are just
being tweaked right now but one of the
reasons I wrote the book is where an
investor in many companies and we can
basically count which ones are doing job
displacements and we see for example we
have invested in companies that are
doing rope robotics for dishwashing
fruit-picking
we a loan officer customer service and
traders and weight waiters and
waitresses fast food cooks cashiers so I
can think of eight jobs already that the
technologies I see making rapid progress
probably I mean you can add taxi drivers
I assume and truck drivers that's right
we are investing on Tottenham's vehicle
yes those will be quite a bit later but
the the eight professions I mentioned I
think between three to ten years they'll
be largely gone but I find fascinating
about those professions that you
mentioned this is two things one they're
they're low skilled labor
yes and second they often have a
physical extension where you can't pick
fruits but just having you know Peter
thinking about picking fruits but they
have to be a physical robot and that
board has to be food safe do you
envision a new age of robotics age of
robotics as in robots getting smarter
and able to many people look at the
business of robotics from my perspective
except for self-driving cars I can't
point at a single robotic technology
that has really succeeded at scale mmm
there's bits and pieces there's Kia and
Amazon that's like shelf delivery and my
analysis has been like in addition to
being smart you also have to pay for the
hardware and maintain the hardener yeah
but you're saying no not so fast
Sebastian there's all kinds of drops
there it's not just the ice also the the
physical actuation that's gonna make
enough progress is that is that what
you're saying yes I think I'm projecting
that but I also am more cautious in
projecting that slowly and we have to
see there's equivalent progress in the
mechanical aspects but I believe we're
seeing progress and also computer vision
and deep learning and those technologies
are getting into
and we're seeing functional prototypes
actually probably the first one will be
the Kiva 2.0 right the version that's
completely human free in the warehouse
putting things in boxes that I think we
certainly we see if you are a young
enterpreneur bead in the United States
in China or anywhere in the world
what should you work on if you want to
do something significant nei well what
are your best ideas yeah no one's
listening well if you're into making
money the lowest hanging fruit has to be
in the financial areas because those are
fabricated human symptoms of simulation
that were never meant for people to do
so all the banks insurance companies
payments investments I think that's the
because that you end up with a cash
printing machine now once you your
algorithm works it's it doesn't have all
the robotics and warehouse and
manufacturing delivery all those all
those things so I think if you're into
making money there's still space in
financial yeah if you're into making a
huge difference then I think getting
into robotics autonomous vehicle those
are probably the breakthroughs there
will probably come back to help many
things become possible good autonomous
vehicle I think is a particularly
challenging one I'm not as optimistic as
way mo in saying okay we're gonna deploy
this year and next year this this and
that will happen but I think with so
many smart people and money going into
it with all the automotive companies in
electrical vehicle companies having
given up two autonomous vehicles I think
they will eventually make progress and
change the way we transport ourselves
and when that happens a lot of those
technologies will then come back to
robotics and and maybe solve the robotic
problems that you you think maybe are
hard to solve at the moment I mean
anyway listening we have an AI and
Finance not a degree that is launched
but more importantly blockchain so I've
heard opinions on blockchain form like
this is just a nice piece of puzzle that
peeps this is great for drug money all
the way to it's gonna change everything
where you stand
I think we got to solve the powa
so that is the large amount of
computation needed to maintain that an
ultra bility of the contracts so when
someone solves that problem either with
some kind of some form of compute that
that doesn't kill us with energy or with
a non compute intensive approach I think
it can take off I think there will be
many applications would you invest in
boxing yes yes invested in boxing only
in a great company called bit me it's
somewhat of a blockchain company is the
largest bit Bitcoin mining hardware
company well we look when we look at
this layers of things you can invest in
their icy OS and crypto we're very
worried about fraud there we look at
blockchain we don't see the killer app
or worry about PAP o.w but from an
investment standpoint the one place you
can't lose is whatever the apps are you
gotta keep the mining going you know
you're gonna do shop the shuffle so we
did you know El Dorado California
everybody's mining for gold occasion
people succeed but you have a fixed
business because you give everyone the
same trouble that's right it's is our
single only investment in blockchain
nice and I think we've been pretty smart
if you were a bank if you were a bank
and you just been hidden without Frank
and with Basel 3 and all these
regulations that came up 2008 crisis and
you you're racking up hundreds literally
hundreds of windows every year in
regulatory and compliance costs should
you worry about blockchain if I were a
bank
I just shut myself down cuz I'm not
doing any good for the society
I think it should all be electronic I'm
just I'm partly kidding I'm partly I'm
hardly kidding but apparently serious
because we're in China I the credit card
companies are already gone you know the
mobile payment is already taken over and
that 2% of tax that you know that's been
placed on the Western world is gone
China just freed itself from a 2% tax
from not having to use credit cards by
using purely this is not you know block
this is not blockchain nor is it nor is
a crypto it's just real solid normal
renminbi currency that is being
exchanged on WeChat I mean China you see
people paying each other always by phone
nobody carries cash people don't have
credit cards even beggars on the street
are they're holding up a sign that says
I'm hungry scamming you know and I think
in that we see the future of money and
whether there is block Chang or crypto
so what what can what can say Jamie
Dimon from JPMorgan Chase or was ruiner
from Credit Suisse but can we actually
learn from China well I think the future
of Finance will go completely virtual I
think all the people in banks are doing
jobs like routine you know lab rats in
the in the will they should all be done
by AI so I realize there are a lot of
regulations that don't allow banks to
just go away but but I think I think
banks will probably be too slow to
reinvent themselves with block what's
blocking or without and we will end up
with really just virtual currency
virtual banks and that and pay less and
less I mean if if credit cards are
taking a 2% tax banks surely are taking
another 2% tax on the society insurance
companies surely taking another 2% I
just look for the day that this narrow
AI will displace those things and give
that 6% back to us that we are entitled
to some insurance companies insurance
companies live
by leveraging risk okay and if a I were
to be really smart it would say things
like okay you're number one factor of
risk is your pre-existing conditions and
number two of risk is your lifestyle as
measured by your credit score or
whatever you use for lifestyle
measurement it doesn't even take a guy
to get there don't you avoid that we got
into a world where we just don't have
insurance anymore and we'll just be
winners and losers oh no I think
insurance should be personalized based
on the risks you have and the need you
have so I think everyone should be able
to design his or her own insurance needs
of saying well I want you know you can
not a natural language describe that's
if I die I want my family to have this
much money so how much do I need to pay
you and click and then a personalized
policy will come and you pay for that
and if you have a pre-existing condition
you're gonna pay it twice as much if you
have a pre-existing condition
I mean you went to a pre-existing
conditions and pioneer life I do I do
if government's want to enforce that
insurance companies must do something I
mean whether it's virtual or physical
they can enforce that I mean yes I I
have a my medical insurance did not
abandon me once I had cancer right and I
can't get any other insurance company so
I better hang out to this one but the
same can apply to unfortunately surance
no okay yeah I will change course a
little bit and talk about young people
because many of our Udacity fellows are
people in the world aspiring to be even
10% of who you are carefully you're a
role model to us to many of us myself
included but if you face your younger
self say it Ching hua university or
Carnegie Mellon University what advice
would you give to yourself hmm
well especially consider the age of AI
is coming I think it's all the more
important that the young people follow
their heart and do things they're
passionate about because this what the
world tells you is increasingly getting
outdated because I think a lot of
parents and a lot of jobs in the society
would have us think that some jobs are
very desirable because they're stable
safe or some jobs are desirable because
they're high-paying but AI would disrupt
a lot of that take radiologists for
example you know that would be if you're
going to medical school don't be a
radiologist
don't be dermatologists either don't
yeah exactly don't be a dermatologist
yeah and yeah you did some work on that
right you are you and Andrew are both
doing great work on that but do be a
researcher right so so one is you know
do what you're good at and what you love
and second is be aware of what AI is
going to replace and don't go into those
area go into the areas where AI one
hands think about AI as either a job
destroyer or a job enhancer pick the
jobs where AI can be a job enhancer be a
medical researcher right that that is a
is a great great area but but some some
jobs will go away also I think it's
important to improve the human
interaction skills because that's one
thing I cannot do is that true human
touch that the compassion the empathy
the altruism the connection and the
trust with people and that soft skill
sometimes are being forgotten by young
people who spend all the time on the
phone so do spend time making friends
going to team work activities even
before the age of AI we know that in
corporations people with strong EQ
actually is more important than the IQ
of course you want both but everything
else being equal you have a basic level
of both people with high EQ are
generally the ones who really progress
well in the careers interesting I'm
gonna ask you one last question and I
believe in over the answers but only
asking anyhow because you and their
leaders do you think that we ever be an
age that we can upload ourselves into a
computer
I'm going to I'm going to say no I would
like I would not like that to historians
in the world take moment notice here
carefully what expert says will never be
able to put us in a box well I I'm not
saying we're in that we can never do it
I'm saying I would very much like the
answer to be no and the reason is I
think our life has meaning because of
our mortality and this pursuit for
immortality will disrupt the reasons of
how we live our lives and I think
there's a lot of wisdom of accumulated
over thousands of years so if we offer
immortality to people I worry that our
humanity will change in a way that may
be very negative I'm not projecting it
to be possible or not possible but I
would very much like it right not to be
would you invest in Chinese version of
calico that tries to W lifespan to
increase longevity or to increase in
mortality to make you live twice as long
increase longevity okay yes absolutely
what about beyond us where our bodies
two-fifty our bodies are only durable
for 120 years right oh you know well
maybe your children's children's bodies
can live longer
I think our bodies have already been
ruined by a pox and toxins and things
like that I was told 120 but but yet but
I think having longevity doubling is I
think I would love to invest in that
okay now since that didn't break my
final cast and I run right now no final
question among all the great things to
mean discuss today from the EE human
lifespan to cold fusion to flying car so
queuing all diseases like what do you
think is gonna actually happen next act
30 or 40 years well I think a lot will
happen I think you flying cars will
clearly happen autonomous vehicles will
clearly happen narrow AI taking half the
jobs that will clearly happen that's big
yeah a lot of the current traditional
institutions will go out of business
that's for sure I think there will be
progress in things like immunology
Anthony of our lives longevity I think
CRISPR hopefully will find a good
direction that can help us be better and
and also I think AI will definitely
cause a couple of small disasters and
hopefully we'll be in a position to
control that - Livia we're out of time
so I can't ask what the disasters are
question but it is so incredible I'd
have you here thank you you're one of my
role models
I've known you for more than twenty
years and it's so great to have you on
stage today at Udacity thank you thank
you
[Applause]